a clearer picture is emerging this
morning in the deadly standoff between
police and a gunman in Stockbridge
Georgia about 20 miles south of Atlanta
police body camera footage shows a
dramatic moment when officers came under
fire but that was just the start of what
was about to unfold Kenneth Craig is
here with that story
Kenneth good morning good morning
Michele this really was a nightmare
situation for everybody involved police
originally went to this home after
getting a frightening call about
possible trouble inside and when they
arrived this situation spiral the
warning now the video you are about to
see might be disturbing to some -
officers were responding to a domestic
disturbance Thursday morning when they
came under fire by the gunman who then
barricaded himself inside the house
shots fired shots fired
automatic body cam footage shows a
chaotic scene as officers are ambushed
almost immediately after they break down
the door of the home
officer Taylor Webb is shot in the chest
and the hip as he enters Officer Keegan
Merritt is seen dragging his rifle
across the front lawn after he was shot
police identified the gunman as 47 year
old Anthony Bailey jr. of Atlanta a
standoff ensued for the next 17 hours as
police pleaded with Bailey to release
two hostages 16 year-old rkv on white
and his mother Sandra white officer
Webb's body cam captured Bailey
threatening police as they surrounded
the house Webb was able to make his way
to the garage where other officers were
able to help him escape police
eventually stormed the home early Friday
and found the bodies of white her son
and the hostage taker who apparently
shot himself
we tried to do everything we possibly
could to bring this to a peaceful
resolution Henry County Police Chief
Mark ammerman said the suspect had a
criminal history that would not allow
him to legally own a firearm white was
due to deliver a baby boy in less than
four weeks White's sister called 911 the
pregnant woman on the ground in the
garage and I ran to the door to Rena
doorbell and I didn't hear anything so
then I came around and that's when I saw
the blood and I tried to get into the
garage and I saw my sister laying on the
ground
we got dispatched to trouble unknown a
lady bleeding the initial officer was
actually putting on rubber gloves
because he thought it's going to help
somebody and according to her sister
white worked as a nurse in the area and
her son who also died played high school
football both of the wounded officers
were taken to the hospital they are
expected to recover from their physical
and whatnot just horrible day the cops
went there to help yeah and they were
wearing the gloves you could see on and
it's hard to imagine with what what it
was like for them 17 hours and of course
unimaginable for the people inside now
Kenneth thank you